are you swallowing them home you're
eating them so fast are they even
touching your tongue girl why aren't you
having any Angela oh I ate so many
already when no one's looking Yeah right
my baby's dieting she wants to fit into
a special child sized wedding gown for
her big day it's one of those exist
it's from my pageant days I was miss
tiny mid-atlantic bride when I was 10
probably heard of it brownies is it huh
pastry cubes made of sugar and fat No
thank you I'll stick with my jerky so
why'd you come in here to socialize and
inform ooh brownies I'm taking two so I
can parcel them up and eat them at my
leisure later on much healthier you're
taking two yeah um but one of them mr.
Toby yeah why don't you send that to him
in Costa Rica um I'm just gonna hand it
to him right now okay weirdo why is that
why is that weird she said she's gonna
give it to him right now she's probably
going to you because they said thanks to
each other yeah they used to Toby works
here again oh can you imagine I don't
know I don't know I don't know what do
you should probably just meander back
there take a look see he's if he's back
dare I you know what I'm going to for
old times sake
great practical joke Jim got me go to
the annex no God no God please no no no
you